you
everyone it's Jerry Aman leeches org and
going to play a 15-2 game let's start
out with Knight f6 see what we get here
hmm
all right let's go with e6 and I guess
we'll be going into names Oh Indian to
make sure I don't allow efore so easily
okay straight in for this huh that's
what I signed up for prepared to give up
my bishop for night and now what I think
I'm going to go for a d6 and e5 setup
you know let's go straight in for this
right now
don't know that I want a Castle kingside
so quickly there are cases where you
could Castle queenside if you can maybe
be a bit more assured that it's secure
there with some v6 e5 setup anchoring a
knight on to a5 to prevent an a5 pawn
break by white so clearly these are some
of the things that's running through my
mind right now
to maybe hold off on committing my king
position I'm wondering about just a 5
right now this seems a bit early I must
say Queen c2 I guess they're just trying
to get an e for and one go sometimes it
would take maybe a couple steps for
white to get that advance in but okay I
guess that's what they're gunning for
the only reason I could see behind Queen
c2 right now that's
I think I'm gonna be playing e5 no
matter what regardless of the epon
regardless of where it goes or if it's
not going to move right away so let's
just get that in right now Queen here I
think this is a fine home for the Queen
Queen e7 c5 this is the first moment
where they're actually thinking okay so
hmm to be a bit careful of Bishop to g5
as well
should I prevent Bishop g5 or wait for
Bishop g5 and then give him a kick and
another kick I'm making some serious
weaknesses on the Kings side by doing
that maybe it's worthwhile to prevent
Bishop g5 altogether hmm other candidate
moves include what exactly queenie 7 and
on Bishop g5 maybe I could actually go
about connecting my Knights h6 and when
the bishop backs up instead of playing
g5 to alleviate this pin I could do a
knight f8 to g6 yeah this is really a
move I want to steer clear of hmm so I'm
looking for something flexible here I
think I like Queen e7 yeah let's do
Queen e7 I think she knows her place
right now yeah let's see
I'm threatening to actually take and
then take on e4 I'd really like to see
d5 because that concedes white gives up
control of c5 and you could be sure
that's Knight will jump in there soon
you know I wouldn't mind seeing the
center close up like this it's white who
has the bishop pair I won't be so quick
to welcome an open position I wonder if
they're gonna go for f3 Bishop d3 is
probably good I think my C pawn wants to
play up - you know I think he knows his
place go at c5 and put some more
pressure on d4 yeah let's do that
have some dark square control if it's in
well with this guy mm-hmm
one thing I have to be careful of is if
I try ignite c6 and they play d5 I can't
play Knight a5 because of Queen a4 and
my knight is picked off so I may need to
preface this knight c6 move with first
b6 also with this 92 move have to be
cautious of a night landing in on f5 and
who's going to be responsible for taking
him out this guy as far as controlling
f5 with a pawn that's just to weakening
to my dark squares so I don't even want
to touch this chief han they're stocking
earlier about playing g5 not wanting to
do that well I don't even want to go one
step forward that said I'm leaning
towards b6 now
touching my bishop at all I basically
want to keep him home just so that when
the night arrives on f5 I could take him
out and only invest one move with this
brush up so I'm leaning towards b6 right
now Bishop g4 I mean it's just pointless
f3 Bishop g4 f3 here G 4 they start
coming at me let's go with b6 it's a bit
Airy over here these light squares but
you know he's not gonna bother me it's
the Queen if any who could maybe try to
take advantage of these squares but I
don't really see that happening Queen a4
I have this so now I think I'm ready for
a night here however I wonder about
first at least considering this capture
it's not really something I want to do
but I should at least consider it this
capture and only then knight c6 to maybe
play against these weaknesses on the C
file you know making sure that my C pawn
isn't on c5 there yeah just exchanging
my seat on I know by making this capture
I'm undoing White's pawns but I'd have
some idea in mind with you know a quick
castles and then maybe throwing a rook
on the C file targeting c5 maybe Bishop
here I'm not sure if I
seat six d5 Knight a5 I kind of hmm what
to say I mean it's maybe a bit too
closed like where would my active plan
be
it's kind of just uh in a strictly
defensive posture going in for that and
on the other hand I don't want to open
the physician up so quickly for the
these uh bishops to be careful of an f4
move I mean I can't stop that so if it's
gonna hit it's gonna hit I think I need
to go with knight c6 right away I don't
think that this is a good idea if I take
they take with the pond knight c6 d5
well I wouldn't mind seeing d5 there and
so maybe it is alright actually you know
what by keeping pressure on this guy
after it takes takes knight c6 this
maneuver into f5 they can't do that so
easily because of my pressure on d4
maybe this is the correct approach so
take first and then play knight c6 and
to be a bit careful of maybe something
like this but yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
give this a shot you know I'm gonna give
this a shot now now I'm opening up the
position this is a bit risky for sure
because I'm opening up the position and
my King is still on Castle I still need
two moves they only need one move
sometimes just being back one move
development wise can be a cause for
concern
so we'll see I'd be happy to see this
move it gives up c5 I can't make as
quick use of it you know when the night
is on b8 it would just take two moves to
get there but still if d5 there's Knight
a5 b7 c5 I will get there
so I maintain pressure on d4 to be keep
my eyes peeled I mean things can open up
maybe with c5 I don't know I don't know
I'm not so sure
well maybe that might be an idea now I
was thinking c5 takes takes takes and
then Bishop e3 but further just that one
moment I'd have a pawn my pawns c5 and E
5 and good control over d4 I could jump
right in there maybe not there might be
some tricks with capturing twice on d4
and then Queen c6 with the fork hmm this
unprotected rook might play a role in
some variations Queen dropping into c6
as mentioned just being one move behind
time wise King stolen castled I'll see
what white comes up with this may be
something given a move I'm pretty much
locked into castling on my next turn
yeah I'd certainly be looking into
castling prior to declaring my light
square Bishop sin tensions I'm not sure
where he belongs
if d5 I'm leaning more towards Bishop a6
targeting c4 this is the move that I'm
fearing most cr5 reason being it's
looking to open up the position at a
moment where White has a slight pull
timewise in the position mind you at the
time on the clock
so other moves maybe f4 if I'm taking
here I don't think I could really hang
on to that pond Bishop b2 and it's
hunted down this is the one pond that I
have in the center I probably should
hang on to him not be so quick to budge
with my e5 pawn if this square has
overtaken I think the center blocks
whole position would collapse this pond
could move maybe as a pawn sacrifice and
these pieces are Unleashed yeah if
Bishop g5 I think I will go in for h6
and g5 just to because otherwise you
know f4 is hitting within this idea of
capture and then taking on f6 doubling
my F pawns yeah I think I would have to
resolve this pin if Bishop g5 is played
the h6 and g5 clamping down on f4 I'll
sing interesting options for black
Bishop g5 Knight f4 Queen here I just
play here d5 I go a Knight a5 a4 with
this idea in mind I don't know something
tells me that that's a little bit slow
maybe though might be an idea I gave up
some
we're controlled by making this capture
I've undone their pawns as well so let's
see what is white chewing on here
I think g3 to f5 no I'll take on d4 and
hit the Queen pawn moves are the
scariest to me at least scary is d5 well
I guess h3 as well all right they're
really coming out any full force here
huh all right all right so I have to be
careful because it's threatening to take
and after I recapture Bishop g5 and I
mean that pin that I didn't want to be
in so how do you do how do you do how do
you deal with this hmm this seems way
way too slow but is it important I do
that hmm it is certainly weakening very
very weakening wait a second could I
consider maybe I could play it in a way
where I allow my double allow doubled F
pawns here's maybe something I could
consider this this point here is extra
sensitive and so I'm giving some strong
consideration to Bishop g4 taking the
night out and then landing here Bishop
g4 takes takes
takes again I could take with the night
I may end up with double deaf pawns but
they're giving up their dark square
bishop to do that I would have a strong
knight on e5 also at this point if we
take twice here on e5 maybe Queen c5
would play a role at some point maybe I
should view it like that as well their
King is a little bit more exposed with
that F pawn advance let's give that a
shot
Bishop g4 I'm trying to hop into d4
that's the primary function of this
trying to put some indirect pressure on
their center pressure on the knight
influencing the d4 square and d5 now I'm
taking here first and then jumping in
takes I've got a recapture this is too
slow if they're taking on e5 takes
Bishop takes the knight they take here
and Beyond there on my queen sorry
capture this is an unprotected piece
Queen a 4 I think I have to come back
here I need to not only defend the night
but break the pin if Queen a4 so as
mentioned if d5 this might be a resource
this would increase my control over d4
in a very tense position you know very
tense middle game right now
I like that this bishop is a at least
for the moment at all pond you know he's
not seeing any of the white squares on
my side of the board I like that my pond
kind of controls this night okay well
this was my idea to take the night let's
do it I need to get into that d4 square
you know I think I should do that right
now inserting a check isn't good let's
jump right in so two knights versus two
bishops I have a good square for my
knight but I kind of feel like he will
be undermined soon but maybe not Knight
here is maybe a threat maybe they have
to play Queen here to stop me from
getting rid of their dark square bishop
it's be careful
here's another thing I could look to
jump in here and even I'm even seeing a
position where I could play this where
I'm down upon but still have a strong
night versus a not-so-good Bishop yeah
kind of liking my position not a hundred
percent on that but you know I'm seeing
that I could find good squares for my
Knights at least so that's a bit
comforting you know this Knight meant
overnight d7 into c5 or if there is a
capture here maybe knight on e5 so if
something like queen of two night here
rook moves I take the bishop and then I
could think about Knight d7 into c5
there should be strong okay they're
stopping Knight b3
think I want to stop Bishop g5 so I'm
looking to reposition my knight right
now just under five
if ninety seven right well I have to
stop Bishop g5 hmm 97 Queen g4 hmm I may
even be able to go now play this
position where I'm down the exchange 97
queen g4 King site Castle Bishop h6 g6
Bishop takes rook rook takes and in the
end they're up the exchange but I have
two nights with I believe two pretty
good squares as Holmes that I can rely
upon well I think I'd certainly need to
sidestep this Bishop g5 move so let's go
with this I'm a little bit concerned of
Queen g4 right here but I think their
other move is Bishop e3 which I'm not as
worried about I think I'll be okay with
giving up upon if they try Bishop e3
take and then retreat the bishop and
then takes here that's what they're
going for however maybe I should make it
a bit more difficult wait a second I
should probably castle right now 95
Bishop takes there's pawn push and I
can't take because of rook e1 I gotta
get off this file
I gotta get castled let's do it now and
can I make it a bit more difficult for
white to track down this Knight Bishop
back here I could play Knight c5 and
Bishop takes pawn takes Queen takes I
have Knight b3 this other night could
observe the b3 square with the
or possibility maybe they go with the
Bishop e2 basically saying I'm fine with
with it if you want to give up your
night for my light square Bishop which
case maybe I just again play this
position where I'm down upon but I still
have I'd have a strong night versus the
light square Bishop try to show some
compensation I think there would be some
compensation with my dark square control
especially over II five after this
capture with maybe queen or night Rokon
c8 he is backward
Wow what do you got brewing over here
man huh what's the story with that
little Queen h5 didn't consider that not
quite sure what it's doing 9c five I
could hit the bishop seems like a good
start
I'm on the bishop there's no time for
this in a push well maybe that's what
they're lining up hmm-hmm all right
let's start with this
there's no Bishop takes pawn takes in
pawn push but that's what they're trying
to do to then target h7 I may have to
play this as weakening as it is to my
dark squares g6 and then f6 you know are
you playing f6 soon I got to take back
some control the dark squares you know
let's go here also some lateral defense
all right hmm
can I hold this did I miss an
opportunity for a night check as soon as
the Queen dropped in here maybe f6 was
too quick
should I have played that I don't know I
have some pretty easy moves coming up
that the doubling of the rooks now the
Queen retreats in Bishop h6 is a threat
I'm going to reposition this Knight to
d6 he could even return to f7 maybe at
some point to control these uh these two
dark squares maybe something like that
even if my G pawns are doubled I might
have to do this taking and pushing I
don't think is working hmm
tense game this is the most natural
pressure on f6 a knight on d6 throws
some punches the block hating square
he is a passed pawn good idea to keep
him under control I'd like to have some
exchanges of the major pieces this
position Queens off in particular I
could uh I have some concern about
King's safety with still the all these
major pieces on board so that would that
would help me out I'd really like to see
them cash in Bishop takes Knight and I'd
much rather play this position with this
exchange me to being down upon instill
this dark square control but it seems
like they're on top of that and I don't
I don't see them going in for that they
had a moment earlier where they could
have gone for that so if they're not
going for it if they weren't going for
it then
I don't see it happening I don't see it
happening now yeah I should have a way
to defend here Queen night he's not
playing if he's going to play you have
to make this capture but then he's not
playing Knight Queen and rook are good
defenders here I believe this is an
alright structure means Queen g7 if
needed
alright some more pressure against f6
Bishop here may be an idea you have to
play here maybe I don't have much time
I gotta make a move I'm weakening white
squares but I have some light square
control with my Knights it's still a
weakness I'm setting myself up for maybe
h4 but at least with g5 another thing
I'd have to worry about Bishop h6 so on
Queen g4 maybe I go here maybe not
because the bishop takes pawn takes and
then Queen here so now thinking about
hmm let me dropping upon no no however I
could take care beyond their Bishop hmm
bishop
a - if I move the night then there's
this pawn push with the discovery this
is collapsing right here isn't it
gotta try something I'm gonna go for
this
you know if Bishop a - I'm gonna go here
they could take on f6 now get some
trades in I'm on there bishop at the end
so they still need to do something about
that in checking distance
it's my night I have a minute advantage
Bishop a to b5 pretty much have to I
don't want to devote a piece to
defending feel like I'm gonna need my
rooks on the F file or something
takes night I have a new square for this
guy oh they're going in for that night
here as well I guess they're crashing
throwing up six here exchange first I
think that's best
and then queen g6 or Nook f8 I have a
passed pawn if the Queen's are off he
could be a great force I think I have to
do that in a quick rook to f8 Wow I
don't know to make of this I'm just
looking for one more piece to come off
keep these this dark square control wow
I wasn't expecting that my knight is hit
where's a good square I guess here
blockade you know I don't care about my
H pawn I think I'm winning now that's a
strong move let's just push
keep control push here and so let me
actually keep pushing hmm and I go here
rook b8 and then b4 need to activate my
rook
I have f7 controlled if they do a push
trying for rook f7 let's try this and
keep pushing
let's take push over here
rook beat rip b2 King invasion just get
in a check here secure my King position
really tense game hmm
let's come over let's push cut the King
off push again Wow
I don't know that that wasn't right okay
mmm oh I have that fork I almost missed
that still tense right here Wow I gotta
go after their pawns whoo my goodness
do not know what to make of this still
very tense
got to keep my knight there hmm
gotta get my king up now they have to
watch out for some Forks my Knights
gonna be trapped isn't he yeah I'm
completely cut off here
oh yeah he's just getting hunted down
yeah he's trapped move yeah I'm down on
time here but he's cooked King here man
that was a really really tense game hmm
there must have been a lot of stuff
mister that ending okay let me before I
go over it with the computer I'm
interested with this this position right
around here I think white had a better
approach instead of getting to this
ending I'm pretty sure I had something
right around here
maybe too quick to push that pon could
have also taken here hmm gave a check
yeah I know I had something right around
here I know I did
yeah the computer will offer some good
advice right around this point you were
stopping me from getting to the
second-ranked I really wanted to get
there to attack the bishop and grab him
I'm down upon here but I have a really
strong King position operating on these
dark squares and hmm I gave up that pawn
right my deep on hmm should I have
pushed here I wonder cut the King off
and then they started running I ran went
here I could have even taken right now
Knight takes pawn because their Bishop
is uh he's not really there to defend
yeah I could have grabbed here and then
then done something like this I get one
point in the game I wanted to do this
but I was going to drop the knight
pressure here I have to be careful as
well with the bishop on this square that
are threatening rook here but I could
just take right now rook takes I take
here and then I queen yeah the other
thing well if they do it the other way
I'm just pushing right away yeah so this
was a moment to track down their most
dangerous pawn I went in for the check
and yeah I was basically floundering
right around this point lucked out with
this little fork but it was still
certainly tricky this rook is doing a
really good job of cutting my King off
from approaching these pawns hmm I
wonder if I still had something right
around here it's tough yeah shouldn't I
went with the King move why would I go
with the King move I should go straight
in for this right now and I'm here here
takes you know I'm struggling to to find
a draw even in this one but Wow
tense game let me go right to the
beginning throw the analysis on and have
a field yeah to be expected
and a lot of ups and downs in this one
plenty of opportunities for both of us
all right let's see where we could
improve with this one
NIMS oh and you put these arrows on okay
let's get to something apart apart in
this game that's a very critical okay
it's enough it's not that bad
an idea to go with this capture this was
my concern knight c6 here here and yeah
it's solid
I don't know lacking an active plan and
it's a bit worrisome to me here here no
it's another approach but you know and I
don't know about this h5 move giving up
this g4 or a g5 square but okay I went
with this capture knight c6
then f4 Bishop g4 it likes that likes
this move right now but I guess caps
rings alright
they have a slight advantage but I'm
finding good squares for my nights
getting canceled pretty pretty close
game I'd say up front to this point I'd
c5 Bishop back and they'd be three
what's the idea with that I guess just
make sure this bishop has no possibility
of coming to life because I maintain
control over d4 with a piece and Bishop
takes I can recapture with the with the
night on b3 and not the pawn which would
allow its advance and then the bishop to
come to life I'm at g6
too soon to make that weakness and then
here rook here rook c3 narvik c8 of 6
even hmm okay yeah you know yeah I
certainly liked this idea now because
what what ended up happening to my F fun
well I lost it by playing g6 + f6 I knew
g6 was super weakening to my dark
squares and I did this in large part I
don't know if I voiced it during the
game but I did this in large part
because of this idea of capturing and
then pushing and having this diagonal
open and you know it's true that okay
well even if this diagonal does open up
I have a moment to then play g6
but my concern was that I lose control
over these critical central dark squares
yet my fear was that this push let me
just show you like I don't know just
making a dummy move this was this was my
fear this move opening this up I could
defend against this threat but now I
don't have this control over a 5 it may
be slipping so that's why I wanted to
kind of preempt this capture capture
push
you know seeing it now the suggestion of
night be three night see to be three and
I could follow up enough six I never and
some capture here no it's wonderful for
black I like this night clear play here
meanwhile you know this doubling on the
F file isn't really throwing a punch at
a pawn now yeah didn't give any uh any
thought tonight b3 well I did earlier
one point pointing out this idea of
landing a fork if the Queen you know if
this capture occurs in the Queen I could
get the exchange like that as far as
just reinforcing it at this stage I
didn't consider Knight b3 doesn't really
like this little maneuver well yeah I
don't know about that and a computer
chess huh Queen takes a three greedy
computer hmm I grab the pawn it wants to
go with Bishop to a2 here I'm just
dropping up six no that's why I didn't
play it I thought this oh my goodness
they don't have rook f6 I could take and
then play ninety two if they take the
Queen back there getting mated rook
takes Bishop back take the bishop mate I
didn't see that resource I could have
played Queen g7 here instead of grabbing
the pawn queen back and then take mmm
and I'm hanging on to my F pawn and my
nights are looking quite annoying here
oh that would have been a nice tactical
thing to see that Knight to e2 move rook
takes f6 is a great blunder mmm okay so
I took and I thought I'd have to play b5
yeah
crashing through enough six they have a
pawn advantage so I took they took here
they're still with the plus not that
great of an advantage this might be one
that the computer has to think about
some more to I mean I wonder how much
weight it's really giving to these pawns
here who I believe I can keep under
control it's a strong piece this is a
passed pawn they have to pass pawns but
they're under control well at least the
e pawn Czech king f6 and now it's equal
get this guy rolling
what is it suggesting here h3 yeah I was
trying to at this point get my rook
active but and that was my idea by
pushing these pawns here to create some
pawn break on the A or B file I think
didn't look over towards the H and G
file for that so I guess this is good
hitting the pawn and threatening to
simply dislodge my Kings position on the
sixth rank push they give check and yeah
now I'm losing control for sure my
knight has to go elsewhere mm-hmm well
they didn't go for that no okay
for just a moment I'm slightly better
and now I am better this was around the
moment I thought I was but make it and
making it happen was a different story I
felt that if I played before they play a
four and shut it down still crying out
for this if they take I play over with
the rook but if they push I guess he's
now a target for a Knight g4 Knight here
grab here tough ending this is the only
way that I saw in the game that I could
force the opening up of the position
with a four rook to b8 and then B for
the answer they
anticipated that well okay seven
preparing to meet v4 with rook takes a
four we had exactly that I take and what
am i doing why did I not go rook to be
two right here oh my goodness
I had my opportunity to play up to v2
which is what I was wanting to do mmm
rook b2 right now right now rook to be
two and they have to run in Reverse I
have them boxed out with my knight in
pawn tough move to wrap my head around
and then here don't quite understand
that I'd probably take care
hmm that's still tricky because he's not
too long off from promoting but yeah I
should have definitely got to that
second rank I don't know what I was
thinking there got in with my king it
still likes I have something here which
is pushing the pond it's trying my best
to get in there banking a little bit of
time right around this point you had my
opportunities here didn't consider the
push push here maybe even around this
point I could think about pitching the
pond but now I do get to this second
ranked strong King position strong rook
position strong night mm-hmm
plenty of chances in this one too very
tense one one of the more intense ones
I've played recently check and when it
gets to this point yeah it's still not
winning even though I'm up that piece
hmm yeah cuz he's
that uh you know he's kind of boxed out
and this move is really quick so tough
to hold from here but I guess it still
is holdable hangover right there maybe
not
mmm and then you hear didn't it just pop
up mate in 17 yeah mate in 17 yeah and
there's nothing here the rook is a
fantastic piece boxes up my knight even
calling out for a rook here and where's
my knight going nowhere
King all the way up like this just like
they were gunning for in the game and my
knight is picked up hmm really tense
game I took some interesting things away
from this one I didn't appreciate this
Knight to b3 move right around here too
quick to weaken how to say it maybe I
was a bit too quick to make this highly
committal move g6 and you know I saw it
during the game as weakening these dark
squares but on top of that it is also
setting myself up for some serious F
file pressure you know sure enough my F
pawn falls in this one and you know
that's another negative with this
advance it's not just the squares you're
weakening but this this F file pawn now
because you've because I've weakened my
F six square it's this F pawn who's now
going to turn out to be a great target
for white you know this idea with
securing d4 with the piece and then
solidifying my Center with f6 and then
looking for this move to put some
pressure on there pawn that would have
been a much much more solid approach
clearly okay well as usual feel free to
leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you